y
[Música]
el mundo empieza a aislar al sur de
áfrica en un intento por contener la
propagación de la nueva variante de
coronavirus llamada omicron por la oms y
cada vez son más los países que aplican
restricciones de vuelo y otras medidas a
viajeros procedentes de hasta 8 naciones
de áfrica
la violencia empaña el camino a las
elecciones presidenciales en honduras
que se celebrarán este domingo políticos
y funcionarios públicos del país han
sido asesinados o amenazados por cuenta
de bandas criminales que se creen son
contratadas por rivales políticos
tendremos informes de nuestros enviados
especiales
la onu condena el clima de impunidad por
las desapariciones forzadas en mexico el
órgano de naciones unidas que supervisa
esta problemática también criticó la
ineficacia y la discrecionalidad que hay
en las investigaciones en un país donde
se desconoce el paradero de más del 95
mil personas
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos hablando
sobre la creciente preocupación
internacional por la nueva variante del
coronavirus omicron república checa- se
encuentra examinando un caso sospechoso
mientras que alemania teme que haya una
alta probabilidad de que esta variante
ya se encuentra en su territorio al
detectar mutaciones características en
un pasajero que llegó de sudáfrica otras
61 personas provenientes de ese país
dieron positivo al llegar a países bajos
y actualmente se realizan pruebas para
determinar si son portadores o no de
omikron eeuu canadá brasil y la unión
europea- tailandia y australia son solo
algunos de los que han empezado a
aplicar restricciones a viajeros
provenientes de hasta 8 naciones del sur
de áfrica con previsibles impactos para
la economía de esa región del mundo
para muchos una salida precipitada a las
4 de la mañana me enteré de que gran
bretaña había vuelto a incluir a
sudáfrica en la lista roja y luego a las
6 de la mañana nos enteramos que había
una posibilidad de retorno así que
conseguimos los dos últimos asientos
desde el anuncio este jueves del
descubrimiento de una nueva variante del
cob y 19 bautizada como omicron la lista
de los países que prohibieron los vuelos
de sudáfrica no para de alargarse reino
unido canadá francia singapur
restricciones que llegan en mal momento
es el inicio del verano austral en
sudáfrica es decir la alta temporada
turística en el país más visitado de
toda áfrica austral hora de flete ya me
tocó dejar ir a las mujeres que
trabajaban conmigo ahora que cancelaron
los vuelos es decir no habrá más
turistas se cerrará el negocio guau en
los paisajes de sabana animales salvajes
cañones y selvas el turismo en sudáfrica
representaba 1 de cada 10 empleos antes
de la pandemia
detenidos por primera vez todo el mes de
diciembre reservados todos los
propietarios de hostales y hospedaje nos
dicen que todo el mundo canceló
mala noticia
el gobierno sudafricano denunció medidas
draconianas e injustas contra el país
muchos de los países que optaron por
medidas drásticas están luchando a su
vez contra la cuarta ola
la nueva variante omicron descubierta en
sudáfrica posee múltiples mutaciones que
la hacen muy contagiosa la organización
mundial de la salud desaconsejó las
restricciones de viajes en el país
una nueva jornada de protestas se vivió
en australia en rechazo a la
obligatoriedad de la aplicación de las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 miles de
personas se tomaron las calles de
ciudades como sydney melbourne y
brisbane si bien la aplicación del
fármaco es voluntaria a nivel nacional
varios estados han empezado a exigir la
para varias profesiones y han prohibido
que los no vacunados participen en
actividades de ocio como cenas y
conciertos a pesar de las grandes
manifestaciones las encuestas muestran
que el movimiento anti vacuna en el país
sigue siendo muy pequeño
pasamos a américa latina' honduras
elegirá un nuevo presidente este domingo
en medio de una preocupante ola de
violencia que ha empañado campañas
políticas es el caso de alcaldes algunos
amenazados y otros asesinados por cuenta
de la violencia de bandas criminales que
se presumen son contratadas por partidos
políticos rivales el siguiente es un
informe de nuestros enviados especiales
a tegucigalpa andrés suárez jaramillo y
aurora valle
en este cementerio de cantarranas una
aldea a 40 kilómetros de tegucigalpa
clarisa gaitán le lleva flores a su
padre francisco gaytán el que hasta hace
poco menos de un mes era el alcalde del
pueblo
mi padre actualmente
apostaba por el quinto periodo ya tenía
16 años de estar como alcalde de
cantarranas y la única manera en la que
podrían sacarlo del poder es
asesinándolo arrebatándole la vida según
el dictamen forense francisco gaytán
recibió 15 impactos de bala 1 fulminante
mientras presidía una reunión en una de
las aldeas del municipio el mismo que
transformó recientemente para el turismo
dejando como legado una verdadera
galería a cielo abierto también
decidieron hacerle un homenaje a quien
en vida fuera de berta cáceres se llama
me lo dijo el río como pueden ver tiene
el rostro de ella plasmado están sus
ojos
bertha cáceres la icónica líder indígena
y ambientalista también fue asesinada en
honduras destino que temen varios de los
actuales líderes políticos del país uno
de ellos es armando garcía alcalde del
municipio de ojojona quien está
amenazado de muerte pero la intimidación
no loco y ve de seguir en campaña para
su red
estoy amenazado por muchas situaciones
tengo dos periodos tres periodos de ser
alcalde voy por el cuarto de la
población que está conmigo apoyándome
pero
eso me ha traído por secuencia de
amenazas a muerte
garcía y otros 11 actores políticos han
sido amenazados de muerte en el marco de
estas elecciones según la oficina de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos en honduras un temor latente por
no engrosar la cifra de 29 muertes
violentas registradas en el último año
vamos ahora a méjico la onu expresó su
preocupación por el clima de impunidad
en torno a la desaparición de personas
el comité de desapariciones forzadas de
la onu también alertó sobre un notable
aumento en la desaparición de mujeres
niños y adolescentes durante la pandemia
y criticó la ineficacia y
discrecionalidad en las investigaciones
méxico atraviesa una crisis de
desapariciones desde 2006 a raíz de un
polémico operativo antidrogas lanzado
por el gobierno y al día de hoy se
desconoce el paradero de más de 95 mil
personas
lamentamos constatar que se mantiene una
situación generalizada de desapariciones
en gran parte del territorio del estado
frente al cual tal y como venimos
señalando desde 2015 imperan la
impunidad y la revictimización
en otras noticias de mexico una nueva
caravana migrante salió a la mañana de
este viernes de la ciudad de tapachula
en el estado sureño de chiapas con el
objetivo de alcanzar territorio
estadounidense esto en el marco de un
importante flujo migratorio que ha
presenciado méxico este año tres veces
mayor que en 2020 eso es un informe de
manuel acá no
las caravanas migrantes van en camino a
volverse endémicas en méxico cientos de
centroamericanos y haitianos salieron
este viernes de la ciudad mexicana
sureña tapachula con el perenne objetivo
de llegar a eeuu porque pasa común que
nosotros quienes sigue adelante trabajar
vamos a entendernos y otro y uno por
familia así que hay land tapachula no
poder no por nosotros por eso que a
nosotros decidió a sales
los migrantes denuncian el
incumplimiento de las autoridades
mexicanas que según afirman no han
mandado ni los suficientes camiones de
traslado ni las visas humanitarias que
les habían prometido bueno estamos
caminando haciendo una caravana porque
se demora mucho en el médico para dar
los documentos y aquí se hace falta
documentos para muestra vale
el miércoles las autoridades mexicanas
anunciaron que comenzaron el traslado de
los migrantes para su regularización
el instituto nacional de migración
informa que dio inicio al traslado de
personas extranjeras a diferentes
estados de mexico para comenzar su
proceso de regularización migratoria en
el país en paralelo a esta caravana
migrante el territorio mexicano ha sido
testigo de múltiples influjos
migratorios este año cerca de 190 mil
inmigrantes se han detectado entre enero
y septiembre tres veces más que en el
mismo periodo en 2020 y la oficina de
aduanas estadounidense reportó más de 17
millones de personas indocumentadas en
la frontera con mexico
en las islas salomón la policía reportó
el hallazgo de tres cuerpos calcinados
en un edificio quemado en el barrio
chino de honiara la capital las
manifestaciones se ha multiplicado
exigiendo la dimisión del primer
ministro quien en 2019 puso fin al apoyo
diplomático en taiwán a favor de beijing
tercer diario disturbios en las islas
salomón la policía realizó disparos de
advertencia este viernes para impedir a
los manifestantes de llegar a la
residencia del primer ministro van a
seis hogares en la capital hogar a miles
de personas algunas armadas con
cuchillos y hachas atacaron
infraestructuras de la ciudad y
saquearon tiendas varios edificios y
coches fueron también quemados y
destruidos la mayoría de los
manifestantes vienen de la provincia más
poblada malaguita y se declaran
abandonados por el gobierno central las
disputas entre las dos islas se
intensificaron cuando el primer ministro
tomó la decisión de no reconocer
diplomáticamente a taiwán sino a china
en 2019 mientras que las autoridades de
malaya siguieran manteniendo relaciones
con taiwán
creo que detrás de los disturbios los
saqueos y demás está el hecho de que la
gente mala y está quiere que el primer
ministro dimita por las cosas que no
está abordando
tras la petición de ayuda del señor
socavar los miembros de la fuerza de paz
australiana se desplegarán en la capital
y empezaron a tomar control de varias
zonas conflictivas así que estamos allí
para apoyar y esto es un punto muy
importante estamos allí para apoyar a la
policía federal australiana y a la real
fuerza policial de las islas salomón
donde nos requieran les daremos apoyo la
vecina papúa-nueva guinea anunció el
despliegue de 34 fuerzas de paz y el
gobernador general del archipélago david
vanucci declaró un toque de queda
nocturno en la capital
en italia la multinacional ferrero que
fabrica la crema de untar nutella se
lanzó a un desafío busca aumentar la
producción de avellanas locales de cara
a depender menos de turquía el principal
proveedor del mundo la marca está en el
comienzo de un programa que tiene como
objetivo incrementar la producción de
avellanas italianas en un 30 por ciento
pero este cultivo no es del gusto de los
habitantes y asociaciones
medioambientales como nos lo explica
nuestra corresponsal natalia mendoza
desde el cielo se ven por todos lados
avellanos hasta donde alcanza la vista
en esta provincia a unos 60 kilómetros
al norte de roma el 90% de la superficie
arbórea está dedicada al cultivo de
avellanas
romeo es un emprendedor agrícola antes
en sus terrenos crecían los cereales
pero como muchos en la zona ha decidido
cambiarse a las avellanas mucho más
rentables
la ventaja del cultivo de avellanas es
que no necesita de mucha mano de obra y
no tenemos problemas para venderlas
contrario a lo que pasa con las frutas y
las legumbres que vendemos directamente
al consumidor las avellanas las vendemos
a la industria y eso tiene ventajas las
ventajas son tener un cliente como la
empresa ferrero y el productor de la
nutella encargada de un programa que
compra al menos el 75 por ciento de la
conciencia anual de avellanas algo
atractivo para las más importantes
cooperativas y productores el propio
alto neutralidad cuando el programa de
ferrero busca darle la tranquilidad al
productor para que tenga la certeza de
que su producto será comprado y nos
permite vender al mejor precio bien sin
embargo el monocultivo de avellanas con
alto consumo de agua está acusado de
perjudicar el ecosistema local
que es un cultivo intensivo que emplea
pesticidas utilizan tes sustancias
químicas que se vierten en el agua ente
arriba y obviamente por eso favorece el
desarrollo de algunas algas tóxicas que
genera un cóctel de sustancias tóxicas
cancerígenas cancheros la agencia
regional para la protección del medio
ambiente ha confirmado la toxicidad del
agua del lago que alimenta los
acueductos de comunas cercanas sus
habitantes están divididos entre la
preocupación y la resignación la juana
potable el agua no es potable nos dicen
que a priori podemos cocinar con ella
pero tengo dos niños pequeños prefiero
no arriesgar entonces compró toda mi
agua en botella chile-italia tiene
previsto aumentar la superficie de
cultivos de avellana en los próximos
años para llegar a las 90.000 hectáreas
de aquí a 2025
y en francia el que es considerado el
mercado navideño más emblemático del
país abrió sus puertas el viernes en la
ciudad de estrasburgo este tuvo que ser
cancelado el año pasado por cuenta de la
pandemia y esta vez abrió en medio de
restricciones el ministerio de sanidad
confirmó el jueves que el ingreso a los
mercados navideños en el país estará
condicionado al porte del pase sanitario
y el uso obligatorio de mascarillas
francia al igual que otras naciones
europeas registra actualmente un repunte
de casos de kobe 19
de esta manera despedimos este
informativo en francés 24 pero los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
www france24 puntocom para seguir la
actualización de nuestras noticias
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]